Welcome to whatever this is.
-♪ (MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING)
Our main story tonight
concerns immigration,
the system that brought you me.
But, it's still good,
and I promise that
won't happen again.
(APPLAUSE)
Last month, some idiot paid
106 dollars
for possibly the largest
Raisin Bran flakes in the world,
and let me just say, that idiot
is very happy with his purchase.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And Utah even voted
to legalize medical marijuana,
which means that
in the not-so-distant future,
there is a genuine chance
that Mitt Romney
could be lying on a bed,
stoned out of his mind,
giggling and asking his wife,
"Do you think we have, like,
too many sons?"
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
Hashtag "Jeff We Can"--
"Crack Pipes"--
"Find Kadyrov's Cat"--
"Mom Bombs"-- "Flat Earth"--
"This Is A Pyramid Scheme."
Spending good money
on a poorly-made wax figure
of a former president
sounds pretty stupid, right?
I'm proud to say
we bought five of them.
-Damn, Warren, you nasty!
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
(LAUGHTER)
You believe there could be
an infinite number
of parallel universes.
Does that mean
that there is a universe
where I am smarter than you?
(THROUGH SPEECH GENERATOR)
Yes...
(AUDIENCE LAUGHS)
And he's so fucking smooth!
-We got him! We got him!
-(HORN BLARES)
(YELLING)
(SHOUTING)
Are you not entertained?!
♪ (MUSIC INTENSIFIES) ♪
♪ (MUSIC STOPS) ♪
That's our show!
Good night!
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS)
-♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪